ليس تصعيدا عسكريا مفاجئا حتى لو مرت
ساحته بفتره طويله نسبيا من هدوء ف
ناغورني كارباخ اقلي مسكون منذ عقود
بتعقيدات داميه لعلاقه في غايه الصعوبه
بين اذربيجان وارمينيا كما في محطات سابقه
مر التعامل بين البلدين مع المشكله
المزمنه بينهما سريعا نحو التصعيد العسكري
في منزلق ميداني نشطت الدبلوماسيه الدوليه
بشانه لوقف الامور عند حدها الاتحاد
الاوروبي دع الى وقف فوري لاطلاق النار
بينما كثفت كل من انقره وموسكو صالته ما
سعيا لمنع اتساع رقعه الاشتباكات خلافات
قديمه تتجدد وفي كل مره يخلف ضحايا وقلقا
اقليميا بالغا انها قصه ناغورني كارباخ
النزاع الذي اعيا الى حد الان كل المساعي
لانهائه تقرير احمد
عس رغم المفاوضات ومرور وقت طويل على حاله
الهدوء لا يبدو ان الرغبه في القتال قد
بردت تعيد هذه المشاهد من اقليم ناغورني
كارباخ العالم الى العام
1994 تندلع المعارك بين اذربيجان المصره
على تباعيه الاقليم لها ومقاتلي الاقليم
الذي اعلن استقلاله احاديا ومن خلفهم
ارمينيا المنازعه لاذربيجان في سيادتها
على ناغورني كارباخ فالاقل الذي يصح وصفه
بالقنبله الموقوته او بالبركان المتفجر
بين الفينه والاخرى تتشابك فيه حسابات
عرقيه ودينيه وجغرافيه وتاريخيه وسياسيه
اذ تقطنه اغلبيه ارمينيه تصل ل
95% ضمن الاراضي الاذربيجانيه وتدعم تركيا
اذربيجان في حين تدعم روسيا ارمينيا وتبيع
الاسلحه في الوقت نفسه لكلا الجانبين
الاشتباكات والمعارك الاخيره اسفرت الى حد
الان وفق روايتي الجانبين عن سقوط قتلى
وجرحى بعضهم مدنيون وزاره الدفاع
الارمينيه قالت ان قواتها اسقطت مروحيتين
وثلاث طائرات مسيره للجيش الاذربيجاني اما
سلطات اقليم ناغورني كارباخ فاعلنت مقتل
عشرات واصابه مئات العسكريين بسبب القصف
الاذربيجاني وزاره الدفاع الاذربيجانيه
اعلنت من جانبها ما وصفته بتحرير ست قر
ومرتفعات كانت تحت سيطره ارمينيا لسنوات
بعد هجوم مضاد شنته في الاقليم ردا على
هجوم من جانب من نعتته بالانفصاليين هناك
تبادل الاتهامات بالبدء والتصعيد في
القتال بين الاطراف الثلاثه اي اذربيجان
والسلطه الموجوده في الاقليم وارمينيا
والتي اعلنت كلها حاله الحرب والتعبئه
العامه رغم دعوات اطراف اقليميه ودوليه
للتهدئه العوده للمفاوضات فالرئيس الروسي
اكد خلال اتصال مع رئيس ارمينيا على ضروره
التهدئه وكد موقف الخارجيه الايرانيه
باستعدادها للقيام بكل ما يلزم لوقف
القتال ومثلهما الاتحاد الاوروبي وفرنسا
الذان اكد ضروره ايقاف جميع الاعمال
العدائيه بين
الجانبين اما الموقف التركي فاصفى الى
جانب اذربيجان متهما ارمينيا بالبدء في
العدوان يقول وزير الخارجيه التركي ان
بلاده تقف الى جانب باكو في الميدان وعلى
طاوله
المفاوضات الموقف التركي هذا اثار حفيظه
الجانب الارميني الذي طالب رئيس وزرائه
المجتمع الدولي بضمان امتناع تركيا عن اي
تدخل محتمل في النزاع وفي ذلك ما يعكس
الحساسيه التاريخيه بين ارمينيا وتركيا في
كل ذلك بدا اقليم ناغورني كارباخ بؤره
صراع وتوتر قديمه جديده تعود المعارك فيها
الى واجهه المشهد لكن الثابت ان ما ستؤول
اليه الامور بين المضي في الحرب او الركون
للمفاوضات وفق مراقبين سيحدد في ضوء
حسابات الاطراف الاقليميه والدوليه
الداعمه لكل من اذربيجان وارمينيا ومدى
استفاده تلك الاطراف من مجريات الاحداث في
هذه المنطقه ذات الموقع
الاستراتيجي لمناقشه هذا الموضوع انضم
الينا من العاصمه الارمينيه ريفان عبر
الانترنت الدكتور دوف هانز نيكو كزان
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في الجامعه
الامريكيه في ارمينيا ومن اسطنبول عبر
الانترنت الدكتور ايلهان مهدف الاكاديمي
الاذر بجاني واستاذ العلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه مرمره ومن عمان عبر الانترنت اللواء
مامون ابو الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ضيوفنا الكرام اهلا بكم دكتور دف هانز
نوكيان ارمينيا اتهمت اذربيجان بالمبادره
بهذا الهجوم
وكذلك فعلت اذربيجان ما الذي يختلف في
تصعيد هذه المره عن المرات
[موسيقى]
السابقه نعم من الواضح ان اذربيجان هي
التي اطلقت هذا الهجوم واسع النطاق في
ساعات الصباح الاولى ضد شعب ناغورني
كارباخ وقد قابت اذربيجان بهجوم واسع نطاق
في الساعه السابعه صباحا بالتوقيت
المحلي باتجاهات ثلاثه غطت جميع خطوط
التماس طبعا
اذربيجان او الناس يقولون عاده
الحقيقه هي التي يمكن كشف النقاب عنها في
بعض الحالات ولكنها هي الضحيه عاده وفي
هذه الحاله مجددا اذربيجان تتبع الروايه
ذاتها ولكن اذربيجان هي التي قامت بالهجوم
وهذا طبعا غير عقلاني طبعا في عام في
التسعينات الارمن كانت لهم اليد الطوله
طيب ومن غير
المنطق تنقلب ارمينيا على عمليه
السلام سالتك عن المختلف في هذه المره
البلدان اعلنا الحرب ما الذي يعني ادى الى
هذا الاعلان ما هو المختلف عن كل موجات
التصعيد
السابقه نعم هذه الحلقه هي ذات نطاق اوسع
الفرق هو انها ذات نطاق اوسع مقارنه مع
ابريل نيسان عام 2016
وحرب الاربع
ايام وايضا المناوشات التي حصلت في يوليو
اذربيجان تستخدم
ذخائره ثقيله و بالاضافه الى ذلك نقول على
المستوى الدولي تركيا تميل الى اذربيجان
وتدافع عنها
بطريقه سنعود الى مناقشه هذه النقط لو
سمحت ل سيد نكوك زيان دكتور نكوك زيان سيد
الهان مهدي
لماذا وصلت هذه المره الامور الى مرحله
اعلان
الحرب المشكله
هي ان
اذربيجان اطلقت مفاوضات
وكانت تتفاوض خلال
27 عام
من خلت مع اربينيا تحت مظله مجموعه مسك
ومنظمه الامن والتعاون في
اوروبا لذلك نحن نتبع الاساليب
السلميه
ل دعونا نقول نمارس ضغوطا على ارمينيا لكي
تسحب قواتها من الاراضي
الاذربيجانيه
وبطبيعه الحال يحدون الامل انكم على درايه
بان القرار الاممي الذي يعود العام
رشح عنه قرارات مختلفه مرتبطه بمطالبه
القوات الارمينيه بالانسحاب الفوري والتام
من الاراضي الاذربيجانيه والامم المتحده
فوضت مجموعه المسك ومنظمه الامن والتعاون
في اوروبا لتصدي لهذا
الامر لو سمحت لي سيد مهديه فقط ننتقل
الان بالحوار الى لواء مامون ابو نوار
لواء مامون البلدان
اعلنا الحرب بحسب متابعتك هل الامور تتجه
الى
هناك يعني هم في حرب منذ مده طويله على
خطوط التماس وعلى المواقع الحدوديه لكن
انا استغرب من الطريقه من النادر جدا يعني
اذا كاي متتبع للحروب زعات العسكريه ان
تعلن كلمه الحرب بهذه الطريقه يعني في
مسميات ومصطلحات اخرى الدول تستخدمها
كالاستدلال الحظر كالاحتفال
الميه الاولى لم نرى من النادر جدا ان
تسمع انت كيف قرات هذا
الاختلاف يعني من النادر جدا ان
تسمعي اعلان الحرب بهذه الطريقه هذا ما
قصدته لان هذا يعني جميع ال الاتفاقيات
وان وصلوا يعني الى طريق مسدود وسيستمر في
الحرب الحرب لا لا يجب الاعتماد عليها لح
لحل مثل هذه المشاكل لكن هذه يعني قضيه
تاريخيه قديمه وحرب مستمره منذ عقود بينهم
طيب التاريخ التاريخ بالنسبه بالنسبه لهذه
المنطقه ما الذي يقوله كيف يمكن ان نقرا
ما سيجري من خلال ما حصل في التاريخ يعني
العالم الع كله يقول ان كارباخ هي تابعه
اراضي تابعه لاذربيجان من امريكا ل منظمه
التعاون والامن الاوروبي ومجموعه منسك
كلها تقول ان هذه اراضي
اذربيجانيه
ا ال
كارباخ يريدوا ان يضمها الى الدوله الام
وهكذا لكن هذا جيب اخترعه ستالين في بعد
الحرب العالميه
وبقى كما هو الامور لا اعتقد انها ممكن ان
تذهب الى حرب شامله لانها تحتاج الى
لاعبين خارجين ليبتو هنالك علاقه تركيه
وروسيه وهم الاهم بهذا الموضوع والايرانيه
ايضا لاحتواء مثل هذا النزاع يعني تركيا
تقول بصراحه
اي دوله واحده
بدولتين امه واحده بدولتين نفس الشيء
روسيا يعني بالحديث عن اللاعبين الخارجيين
نسال نسال الدكتور نيكو كزان عن روسيا
التي دعت الى وقف فوري لاطلاق النار ودعت
ايضا الى الذهاب نحو الحوار هل ارمينيا في
وارد الاستجابه لهذه الدعوه
الان حسنا بادئ ذبد تصحيح سريع ارمينيا لم
تعلن الحرب على اي دوله بما في ذلك ا
والقرارات الاوميه التي تعود العام 1993
غير مرتبطه باعلان ارمينيا الحرب على
اذربيجان هذا فقط هذه فقط مغالطه تاريخيه
قالها الضيف ولكن بالنسبه لروسيا من معروف
ان رئيس الوزراء الارميني اتصل بالرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين منذ ساعتين وكان
ثمه مكالمه من الطرف الروسي او مناشده
وهنالك ايضا مجموعه منسك هناك الرئيس
الفرنسي والوزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه كلهم
يطلبون بدء المفاوضات وتخفيض
التصعيد من خلال او تحت مظله منظمه الامن
والتعاون في اوروبا وه وهذه هي الصيغه
الاساسيه الدوليه التي يجب الاعتماد عليها
للوصول الى حل سلمي لهذا النزاع روسيا
بطبيعه
الحال لديها اليد الطوله في هذا الامر وفي
هذه العمليه بسبب دورها الاقليمي وبسبب
ايضا روابطها التاريخيه نحن في ارمينيا
واذربيجان تربطنا علاقات مديده مع روسيا
واعتقد انه خلال الايام القادمه سوف نرى
الدور الروسي يتكشف ويتبين اكثر فاكثر
لوضع حد لهذا التصعيد الذي دفع السيد عليف
نفسه ليعلق
فيه في ظل هذا الكلام سيد الهان مهدف ما
الذي يحول اذا دون ذهاب الاطراف الى
الحوار بالنظر الى ال كل الجهات التي دعت
للذهاب اليه وعلى راسها روسيا والتي قال
الدكتور نيكو كوزان ان علاقات جيده تربطها
مع اذربيجان ومع ارمينيا في الوقت
نفسه بداذ بد علي القول انني لا استطيع ان
اسمع صوت زميلي الارمي
نتحدث هنا عن المفاوضات لماذا المفاوضات
هذا هو الملذ الاخير الخيار
الاخير نحن فاوضنا ل 27 عاما
و بلادنا دمرت وهذه المنطقه استوطنها
الارمن في هذه المنطقه المحتله
يعكفون على تعزيز البنيه التحتيه ويقومون
بانتخابات
ويرسلون دعائم ما يسمى الدوله في المنطقه
الاذربيجانيه المحتله كيف يمكن لدوله ان
تتحمل ذلك واذربيجان تحملت ذلك ل 27 عاما
والان و
بعد تسلم السيد باشين سده الحكم و رئاسه
الوزراء نفهم منك اكثر وسمحت لي سيد
مهدي يعني من كلامك هل يبدو ان الحوار
يبدو خيارا متاخرا بالنسبه ل اذربيجان حتى
لو كان عن طريق وسطاء لان دول يعني منها
ايران تحدثت عن استعدادها ل تهيئه اجواء
الحوار بين البلدين حتى لو كان الحوار عبر
الوسطاء يبدو الحوار خيار متاخر بالنسبه
لاذربيجان هل هذا ما كنت
تقصده حاولت ان اشرح ذلك
وقطعتين كيف يمكنني ان اشرح فكرتي
اذا نعم انا احاول ان اشرح انه وخلال
27 عاما مضت تحاورت اذربيجان مع ارمينيا
على نحو ثنائي وضمن اطار مجموعه مسك
ومنظمه الامن والتعاون في اوروبا وكما
تعرفون روسيا هي رئيس مشارك مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وفرنسا في مجموعه منسك
ولكن هل لكم ان تتخيلوا دوله
تتفاوض ل 27 عاما بشان انسحاب القوات
الارمينيه هذه الحكومه الجديده وعلى
الملاه اكدت على ان القوات
الارمينيه لن تنسحب من اي متر من الاراضي
الاذربيجانيه المحتله و بالتالي رموا
العصي في الدواليب الجانبي الارمني وخلال
السنه سنتين ونصف الحكومه الجديده في
ارمينيا
اعلنت على الملاء انها لا تريد
التفاوض وايضا وزير خ سيد مدي لو سمحت لي
انا منحتك الوقت الكافي اريد هذا هذا عرض
تاريخي اريد فقط ان نصل الى نتيجه هل
الحوار خيار قائم الان ام لا هذا ما نريد
ان نفهمه منك هل هو خيار قائم بالنسبه
لاذربيجان ام لا التصعيد العسكري هو
الخيار بالنسبه
ل السلطات في
اذربيجان اؤمن ان الحوار غير وارد الان
والشعب الاذري يؤمن ان الطريقه الوحيده
الطريقه الوحيده
لتحرير اراضيهم من خلال الوسائل العسكريه
لان
الارمن دعوا او وا استجلبوا او دفعوا
الاذريين لهذا الحل العسكري لواء مامون
اذربيجان تلقت دعما
قويا من
تركيا هل من مصلحه الصراع الان دخول اطراف
اقليميه بهذا الشكل بهذا المنحى ما الذي
سيفعله الموقف
التركي نعم بدايه بس رد على ضيفك من يرفان
الارمني انا لما اقل ان ارمينيا او الجيب
الانفصاليين اعلنوا الحرب بال 93 هو سمع
او ما سمع لا اعرف انا قلت انهم اعلنوا
الحرب هذا اليوم ف واتفهم يعني وضعيته
وعنصريته لقضيته هو حر بذلك على اي حال ال
اعتقد تركيا جاده في التدخل فيما لو حدث
او بدا يتوسع القتال ا لان هذا هذا ايضا
يمس الامن الوطني القومي التركي
اي تركيا سوف تحا تحاصر من شمال قوقاس
بهذا المعنى ايضا روسيا خليني اقول ولكن
دول كثيره ايضا معنيه معنيه ب في نطاق
امنها القوبي بما يحصل بين اذربيجان
وارمينيا لماذا تذهب تركيا
وتتفرد بهذا الدور الى جانب احد الاطراف
نحن نشهد حتى الدول التي ربما قيل انها
يعني ستدعم طرفا او اخر ظاهريا دعت الى
الحوار اليوم ونات بنفسها عن دعم طرف دون
اخر يعني روسيا قريبه
لدوله اذا كنا نتحدث عن روسيا اذا كن
نتحدث عن
ايران سوف اتي الموضوع يعني في علاقه قويه
اثنيه لغويه بينهم الاذر بيحكوا لغه تركيه
روسيا سوف يهتز موقعها في جنوب القوقاز
ايران ايضا لها عدد ليس بقليل
من يعني المواطنين الاذريين ف هذه دول سوف
تتدخل يعني ا لا يمكن انا لا ارى الصراع
سوف يتحول الى صراع طائفي لنقل بصراحه
لانه رجال الدين يعني يقفوا موقف معتدل من
هذا الامر اعتقد مجموعه المنسك لن تسمح
بهذا وسوف تتدخل المنظمات الدوليه
الامريكان ايضا يعني يعني بيعترفوا قلت
سابقا ان هذه اراضي اشكر تفضل اشكرك جزيلا
اسفه المقاطعه لواء مامون ولكن انتهى وقت
حصاد الليله اللواء مامون ابو نوار الخبير
العسكريه والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من عمان
الدكتور الهان مهدف الباحث الاذربيجاني
واستاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه مرمره
الدكتور دوف هانز نيكو كزان الاستاذه في
الصراعات الدوليه بالجامعات الامريكيه في
ارمينيا ضيفنا من العاصمه الارمينيه ريفان
عبر الانترنت شكرا جزيلا لكم
جميعا بهذا نص الى نهايه الحصاد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء